et le ton de son côté prépare son
élargissement la suède et la finlande
ont entamé hier les démarches
officielles pour intégrer l'alliance
atlantique et ce jeudi le président
américain reçoit justement les
dirigeants suédois et finlandais à
washington on en parle avec armelle
charrier bonjour armelle que devrait
dit-il se dire durant cette entrevue à
washington joe biden a besoin de
rassurer en fait c'est les suédois et
les flancs des parce que ils ont acté le
fait qu'il voulait rejoindre l'otan
c'est un point qui est important les
pays en tout cas la finlande a
réellement envie de franchir le pas
simplement ils ont bien vu que l'accueil
était froid du côté de la turquie et que
dans ces conditions ça pouvait ne pas se
faire parce que s'il y a un des pays de
l'otan qui s'y opposent l'adhésion est
caduque alors le président américain il
a amené justement ces personnes à penser
que l'otan était la bonne solution il a
vu dans cette guerre avec l'ukraine la
remontée de l'otan donc il faut qu'il
continue à ragaillardir en quelque sorte
des esprits d'autant plus qu'un
processus d'adhésion à l'autre et à ces
noms qui prend plus d'un an et que donc
au milieu de tout ça il va y avoir les
métas américain donc ça va être
important pour son opinion nationale de
montrer effectivement s'il ya une
crédibilité ou non et puis de montrer
aussi la capacité qu'ont les américains
de gérer ce conflit avec la russie et
vous l'avez évoqué ce processus
d'adhésion requiert l'unanimité des 30
membres de l'alliance atlantique la
turquie dont bloque le processus et
tente de monnayer son soutien oui la
turquie a mis un veto catégorique sur
cette entrée parce qu'elle sait que du
coup c'est comme ça qu'elle peut obtenir
des choses
il y a une philosophie qui est toujours
la même pour la turquie qui peut changer
parfois d'allier mais en revanche son
ennemi qu'est le pkk qui sont les kurdes
lui reste son ami quoi qu'il arrive que
ce soit la guerre en syrie que ce soit
le conflit en ukraine que ce soit quelle
que soit la situation dans laquelle la
turquie c'est arrivé le pkk est une zone
impossible à traverser donc ce que veut
demander le président r douanes c'est
soit de vendée au finlandais et aux
suédois de lâcher du coup aller
ressortissant du pkk qu'ils ont sur leur
territoire de leur faire pression
peut-être que dans ce cas il passera
outre s'ils ne passent pas outre dans
ces cas-là il demandera peut-être
d'autres choses et est ce que ce sera
suffisant on en est même pas sûr mais si
jamais est ce que les américains
pourraient arriver en lui fournissant
des f 15 qui sont les avions américains
qui le demandent et que les américains
lui ont refusé depuis qu'il a acheté
s-400 qu'ils sont fermement russe est-ce
que du coup ils arriveraient avoir un
monnaies des changes de cette manière là
peut-être la turquie aussi est très
engagé dans le processus diplomatique
entre l'ukraine et la russie elle
regarde attentivement ce qui se passe du
côté de la mer noire parce qu'elle est
concerné mer noire de l'autre côté de la
rive de la mer noire c'est la turquie
est donc tout cela explique pourquoi est
ce que le président erdogan a
aujourd'hui un rôle majeur dans cette
addition mer